tell us the facts here because you know
there's lots of concern about what
migrants may add or detract from the
economy yes I think first of all we
should see what's happening in Calais in
the overall picture at the moment we
have a humanitarian crisis in southern
European countries we had 100,000
individuals arriving at the shores of
Greece and Italy alone until the end of
May we had hundred eighty thousand
applications for asylum within the
European Union forty percent of that in
Germany alone and the UK received about
7,000 7,000 of the 180,000 so it's
actually a relatively small proportion
which is getting to the UK and asking
for asylum that of course has to do with
the UK being an island and because the
UK is an island there are only certain
gateways and coloured over is one of
these gateways and that's why we see
this concentration of individuals in
Calais who try to come to the UK but
again the numbers are relatively small
so the estimates of individuals sitting
in colour trying to get to the UK are
between two and three thousand at the
moment so we are not really having in
the European context the magnitude of
pressure some other countries in
particular the countries at the
periphery of you of the southern
periphery of Europe are currently facing
but at the same time of course we have
seen an increase as you're saying
overall in applications to Europe as a
whole it's just that we've got a small
percentage of those that is very true
but it is through an increase of course
and what is the impact of that
potentially on the economy well I mean
given that the numbers are relatively
small I don't think that the impact will
be in any way dramatic asylum seekers
are asking for asylum while they are in
the process of their application being
examined they cannot work they have to
be idle at the moment the application is
approved they will
be able to join in the labor market
there were some delays and if the
application is rejected they are asked
to leave the country but given that the
numbers are relatively small as I
pointed out earlier yeah the impact on
the British economy in any direction
will be incredibly minimal some people
will be saying of course they're not
allowed to work but well as such
migrants are waiting to hear whether or
not the application has been successful
they do get paid allowances by the
government is absolutely so that is a
part of the Geneva Convention and it was
the result of the house we have seen in
Europe originating from Nazi Germany and
I would be I am very proud to live in a
part of the world where we are
signatories of the university never
convention and while these individuals
are waiting for their applications to be
approved of course they need to be given
some subsistence otherwise they they
would simply die but again the amounts
we are talking about here are given the
numbers we are seeing coming to the UK
really very small and in particular in
comparison with the pressure some
European countries are feeling at the
moment and of course a fair proportion
of applicants we know as of asylum
seekers do get their applications
approved what happens then you know all
people who were asylum seekers who've
been granted leave to stay are they met
gainers to the UK economy service
vehicle in financial terms well that
depends on the individual case many of
those who come and make their way to
Europe are while we say in in academic
language selected not everybody takes
the hardship is crossing the
Mediterranean and then making up the way
to Europe so we can expect many of these
individuals being come well possibly
high achievers but again that has to be
assessed on assessed on a case-by-case
basis and I cannot make any general
statements how those who say over the
last year attained refugee status in the
UK are will be doing in the
economy perhaps I can tell you that in
10 years time when we have had the
opportunity to look at some data and
assess there are careers in the UK but
very very general times just briefly if
you will it does seem to be the case
looking at your studies that such
migrants do actually contribute more to
the economy than this well so again so
the migrants we have been looking at in
much of our work have been migrants who
either came from parts of Europe
European migrants or migrants who came
from outside Europe but they came for
work purposes for economic reasons and
not for a reasons of persecution and and
therefore we are not refugees and asylum
seekers of course in great talk to you
that's joining us is going it's not very
much